[Music]
inside out from the year 2015 is still
considered one of the most successful
Pixar movies of all time totally
deserved the film also won the Oscar in
the category best animated feature at
the Academy Awards it was all the more
surprising that nothing about a possible
sequel to the film was made known for
years but at Disney's d23 Expo last year
the time finally came and Inside Out 2
was officially announced in it the story
around Riley and her emotions will
continue to be told in today's original
we take a brief look back at part one
and tell you everything you need to know
about the
sequel let's take another quick look at
what the first movie was actually about
we experienced the birth of Riley in the
start of her emotion headquarters from
now on the emotions Joy sadness fear
anger and disgust work together to take
responsibility for Riley's actions and
save her Memories the really important
memories are stored as core memories
which form Riley's personality this is
made up of for example family honesty
ice hockey friendship ship and fooling
around however all is put to the test
when young Riley moves with her parents
from rural Minnesota to San Francisco
after sadness touches on a memory on the
first day at Riley's new school she
begins to cry sadness also causes
arguments with Riley's parents whom she
accuses of being to blame for her
distress in an attempt to salvage the
situation joy and sadness are conveyed
into the Labyrinth of long-term memory
with them the core memories also vanish
and so the two must try to find these
again in order to preserve Riley's
personality a Race Against Time begins
as they both relive Riley's childhood In
The End by working together they managed
to create a new core memory and Riley
can be happy again as we already know
there is a decent time jump in the new
movie namely to Riley's adolescence the
emotions Joy sadness fear anger and
disgust are of course back but it's
entirely possible that other emotions
will be added during this exciting stage
of Life at the d23 Expo Pixar CCO Pete
doctor revealed there may be up to 27
emotions in the upcoming sequel this he
said is necessary to portray the complex
emotions of a young teenage girl the
plot will most likely take place in San
Francisco again and will revolve around
the complex struggles that a teenager
experiences during puberty many viewers
will be able to identify themselves with
topics such as self-doubt physical
transformation as well as the first
butterflies in their tummies so it may
well be that we will witness how the
emotions have to cope when Riley is
rejected for the first time or hurt by a
crush perhaps it's also Riley who's
upsetting someone else and can't really
handle it herself nevertheless the movie
will certainly be aimed at a broader
audience again even though the first
film was about the emotions of a child
for example the connections between
feelings memories and behavior were
universally relevant if the creators put
as much passion and excitement into it
again the yearslong wait for a sequel
will definitely pay
off at least as far as the original cast
is concerned there are some changes
although Amy polar is back as the
original voice of Joy Insider sources
indicate that bill hater and Mindy
Kaling as fear and disgust have dropped
out the reason for this is the huge
salary range among voice actors while
polar pocketed as much as $5 million the
other two were barely offered $100,000
and even though Disney wanted to raise
their pay the two declined with thanks
whether the other dubbing actors will be
back is not known so far the cause for
the rather meager wages is said to be
Disney's new policy of savings when it
comes to animated films this has already
been noticeable in a number of Pixar
films which have been released directly
on Disney Plus instead of theaters such
as the story about the afterlife Soul
the island adventure Luca and the
Adolescent film turning red the script
of inside out 2 is already written which
means that the animation process should
be in full swing by now as with the
previous movie the story was written by
Meg laal however there has been a change
as far as the Director is concerned Pete
doctor will be succeeded by Kelsey man
who has already gathered animation
experience on onward and the good
dinosaur for
example the release date for inside out
2 is currently set for June 14th 2024
according to to the website world of
real we can expect to see the first
teaser trailer for the sequel in
November this would make sense as it can
be attached to Disney's new animation
movie wish which were released in US
theaters on November 22nd in the recent
years Disney also released first
trailers for their big summer movies
around November so it would fit
perfectly to build up hype for the
sequel early once again be sure to
subscribe to our channel to not miss it
and that was it all the information
about the long awaited sequel to inside
out are you looking forward to seeing
the movie and what new emotions do you
think we can expect let us know in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video be sure to give it a thumbs up
thanks for
[Music]
watching